si on avale ces chewing-gum ils peuvent
faire un bouchon et provoquer une
appendicite et ben c'est faux pour
comprendre pourquoi c'est faux il faut
savoir ce que deviennent les chewing-gum
quand on les avale et chewing-gum ça
fait partie des matières non digestives
du coup il reste beaucoup plus longtemps
dans l'estomac et ils mettent beaucoup
plus de temps à faire tout le trajet le
long du tube digestif mais pas plusieurs
années juste quelques heures de plus que
d'habitude il reste plus longtemps dans
le tube digestif mais ils finissent par
ressortir juste il ressortent tel quel
temps bouché l'appendice attention ça
veut pas dire que c'est complètement
impossible ça veut juste dire que c'est
pas une cause d'appendicite connu par
contre ce qui a été décrit par des
médecins c'est des cas d'occlusion
intestinale chez des enfants chez qui on
a retrouvé des masses de chewing-gum
bloqués dans le rectum bref que les
enfants en question ils avaient cinq à
sept chewing-gum tous les jours le mieux
dans le doute c'est quand même de pas
les avaler mais bon si vous en avaler un
de temps en temps et pas de souci sachez
que certaines études suggèrent que le
fait de mâcher du chewing-gum après une
opération pourrait accélérer le retour
du transit intestinal faut juste mâcher
pas